So recall, in the previous, lesson, we talked about using a digital image as
a function, or representing a digital image as a function.
Now what want to try to do is, I want to try to, bring in the concept of how we
can use that, for simple forms of image processing.
Recall in the last lecture,
we talked about that an image is basically a function.
Which is represented by various ways of scanning through it and x and
y and also looking at the intensity values which would be
basically the height map of an image like this.
Using this we basically constructed and stated that now we can actually create
a simple grid, like this, to be able to represent an image, and now we would be
able to pick up the values from each and every element of this matrix.
So, just to review this, what we're trying to do,
is basically we're interested in extracting discrete values of an image.
So what we want to do is sample the whole image,
in the two dimensions, in this case this matrix here.
And look for the values off of this matrix to be
able to do any kinds of computational processes on.
Of course this is approximation because it's quantizing each thing into
a districtized sample and what we basically now have integer values which we
will be then looking for to be able to extract the kinds of values from each
image, which will then be using in different computations